bonjour et merci de nous avoir rejoints
dans file echo l'émission qui revient
sur l'actualité économique locale on
commence tout de suite avec les titres
de cette émission
des transports fortement perturbée cette
semaine les cheminots et il ya les taxis
ont fait grève refus de la réforme
ferroviaire pour les uns opposition au
règlement ont des vtc pour les autres
les dirigeants de tpe et pme ont pu
rencontrer des responsables de grands
groupes aujourd'hui le but nouer des
relations commerciales localement dans
le dossier de la semaine nous
retrouverons les aventures d'axel et
maria deux entrepreneurs lui en courtois
ça y est le brasseur est la gérante de
la crêperie ont lancé leurs activités et
puis dans l'entretien nous parlerons du
club fasse la fondation agir contre
l'exclusion fête ses 15 ans nous
retrouvons le président et le directeur
bonsoir il ya non une personne suivie
par cette fondation vous retrouve dans
un instant mais place à avant cela aux
informations économiques de la semaine
les taxis européens étaient en grève ce
mercredi pour protester contre la
concurrence jugée déloyale des vtc
véhicules de cours tourisme avec
chauffeur des vtc qui utiliserait les
mêmes codes que les chauffeurs de taxi
sans en avoir les droits quelle est la
réalité chiffrée de cvt c'est alors dans
les yvelines par exemple on lille ont
fait leur apparition depuis 2009 on
compterait 170 entreprises inscrites à
la chambre des métiers adhésives il a
comparé au 670 chauffeur de taxi déclaré
cette concurrence importante inquiète la
profession qui constate une diminution
des appels aux taxis vinoy
la situation économique déjà aujourd'hui
n'est pas propice drouy pouvoir on voit
apparaître on voit apparaître
effectivement les
usagers les sociétés qui qui travaillent
avec les chauffeurs de taxi donc font de
moins en appelle aux chauffeurs de taxi
on est de plus en plus inquiet que l'on
voit apparaître aussi donc ces véhicules
de tourisme avec chauffeur sur des zones
telles que versailles saint quentin
autre constat dressé par la profession
le nombre de candidats aux licences de
taxis en très forte diminution
en deux ans ce nombre est passé de 90 à
moins de 30 une licence de taxi coûte en
moyenne 115 mille euros pour les
appartements des civils et jusqu'à 160
mille euros pour le secteur de
versailles saint quentin en yvelines et
puis toujours dans le secteur des
transports 48 % des cheminots ont entamé
hier une grève reconductible
encore aujourd'hui de rer sur trois sont
supprimés l'objet de leur colère la
réforme ferroviaire qui prévoit de
regrouper la sncf et réseau ferré de
france les deux groupes seraient
organisées en trois établissements
publics l'une chapeautant les deux
autres et syndicats estiment que cette
modification ne baissera pas la dette
actuelle 50 milliards d'euros et
craignent que les économies s'effectue
sur la masse salariale
un sujet plus réjouissant maintenant
l'ouverture de la coupe du monde ce soir
à 22h ans paraplégique qui donnera le
coup d'envoi grâce à un exosquelette
fabriqués dans les yvelines à conflans
sainte honorine la société biya y
travaille depuis avril 2013 elle emploie
80 personnes est spécialisée dans la
robotique humanoïde il s'agit d'une
première mondiale une personne
handicapée des meubles inférieur va
pouvoir commander la machine par sa
seule pensée
comment faire des affaires avec de
grands groupes lorsqu'on est une petite
entreprise les entrepreneurs ont pu
obtenir quelques éléments de réponse au
forum business de proximité au gras
organisé aujourd'hui à la communauté
glad d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines des images de
sébastien courbe
ce jeudi près de 130 personnes des
directeurs ou salariés de tpe et pme
sont venus rencontrer des responsables
de grands groupes l'objectif favoriser
le business de proximité autrement dit
permettre aux petites structures de
toucher les géants évinois comme edf
orange ou le crédit agricole nous avons
une préoccupation à travers le
développement de nos activités d'essayer
développer le commerce localement c'est
à dire que dans certains cas on sera
amené à privilégier une entreprise qui
est implanté localement qui travaillera
pour nous edf à l'initiative de cette
rencontre exerce en un sens sa mission
de service public mais les grands
groupes trouvent également un intérêt à
travailler avec des tpe chez orange on
parle de pépites d'innovation
aujourd'hui il présentait aux dirigeants
leur procédure d'achat orange a groupé
or j'ai quand même une grande maison et
parfois pareil compliqué donc un portail
fournisseur qui te permet de simplifier
orange collabore déjà avec 72
entreprises de l'agglomération pour un
chiffre d'affaires de 54 millions
d'euros à la fin de ce forum les
dirigeants des trois groupes présents
ont rencontré individuellement leur
potentiel futur fournisseur un moyen de
dépasser les obstacles habituels presse
qui bloquent ces histoires de taille et
c'est généralement les gros très gros et
les petits récupère un peu les miens je
pourrais arriver à contacter pour par
exemple des cadeaux d'entreprises qui
sont valorisants pour leurs clients
éviter les intermédiaires connaître les
bonnes procédures ses dirigeants
aujourd'hui quelques clés pour élargir
leur clientèle
les communes se prépare pour accueillir
la réforme des rythmes scolaires et
l'heure est aujourd'hui au recrutement
des animateurs qui prendront en charge
les fameux thé appétant d'activités
périscolaires et les besoins sont
importants dans les villes à montigny le
bretonneux un forum de recrutement est
organisée ce samedi matin à l'hôtel de
ville les personnes de plus de 18 ans
qui seraient intéressées doivent venir
munis d'un cv les explications avec
suzanne blanc l'élu chargé du scolaire
le but compléter l'équipe actuelle
d'animateur on en a un peu plus d'une
centaine est donc là on va essayer de
recruter une petite trentaine de toute
façon il faut bafa ou en cours de
préparation du bafa et au delà de ça
aussi bien évidemment certains ont des
compétences particulières elles sont les
ailes sont les bienvenus notant perry
éducatifs seront donc de deux fois par
semaine 1h30 il nous faudrait des
personnes à temps complet puis quelques
personnes volante entre guillemets voilà
donc voilà le type de profil qui est
qu'ils recherchaient
les communes se plaignent de charges de
plus en plus importantes à commencer par
le fonds de solidarité de france un
fonds versés par les communes dites
riches aux communes de plus pauvres
exemple à guyancourt jusqu'en 2011 la
ville étaient exonérées de ce fonds
depuis le mode de calcul a été modifiée
la ville à verser 1,3 million d'euros en
2012 2 millions en 2013 et aurait dû
payer 2,7 millions en 2014 soit 3 % de
son budget total c'était sans compter le
recours déposé par la ville devant le
tribunal administratif relayée par le
conseil constitutionnel
il vient d'invalider le plafonnement de
certaines communes contributrice vous
aviez des communes qui étaient
contributrice mais qui étaient plafonnés
c'est-à-dire ont limité ce qu'elle
pouvait verser quand d'autres étaient
nouvellement contributrice c'était le
cas de guyancourt et devait participer
mais sans plafonnement c'est donc une
injustice formidable le conseil
constitutionnel a donné raison à
guyancourt il a indiqué que ce ce
principe de plafonnement était
anticonstitutionnelle et qu'il doit être
abrogée au 1er janvier 2015 c'est donc
une belle victoire dans la mesure où le
plafonnement sera levé pour des communes
protéger ça veut dire que guillon cours
versera des centaines de milliers
d'euros en moins donc c'est très
important
et durant cet entretien nous allons
revenir sur les actions du club fasse la
fondation fête son 15ème anniversaire
pour cette occasion nous recevons sur ce
plateau son président gauthier prat
bonsoir son directeur mohamed mansouri
bonsoir est à vos côtés de personnes qui
pour nous donner des retours
d'expérience sur les actions justement
menée par cette fondation patricia
agents et passe à fond soir pardon et
face à vous gérald garçonne verger
bonsoir alors gauthier fera donc le club
fasse a été créé en 1999 est-ce que vous
pouvez nous expliquer un petit peu le
l'objet de cette création pourquoi on
fait alors voilà le en 99 c'est le début
de l'aventuré la casse qui à l'époque
mon qui s'appelle san mais a lancé
un vaste plan local pour l'insertion et
l'emploi dont l'objet était de
rapprocher de l'emploi les plus éloignés
et tout ça afin de corps digne de
coordonner les actions des acteurs
publics et par rapport à ça il la brique
supplémentaire pour arriver en fin de
parcours et rejoindre les entreprises
c'est à cette occasion que le club où on
a vu un réel besoin et que le club fasse
a été créé donc c'est un le club qui
permet de mettre en relation les
entreprises avec des publics les plus
démunis afin d'assurer un retour à
l'emploi lutter contre l'exclusion
c'était il ya 15 ans et la casse qui
nous a bien aidés dans cette création et
nous accompagne toujours au jour le jour
et l'action continue donc aujourd'hui à
vous agissez autour de trois axes alors
nous amènerons soir --peut-être lesquels
on tient là alors en fait le principe
d'action du club fasse comme l'a dit
effectivement le président gauthier prat
c'est de pouvoir fédérer accompagner le
monde économique que ce soit des petites
entreprises des pme ou des grands
groupes autour d'actions à caractère
social et sociétal est en fait le club
d'entreprises se veut avant tout un
espace de réflexion des changes
d'innovation et d'action et on développe
quatre champs d'action on a un premier
chant qui est l'école donc là l'objectif
c'est effectivement de pouvoir favoriser
la découverte du monde professionnel aux
prêts
des établissements scolaires du
territoire avec l'association
d'entreprises partenaires alors là ça
peut être par exemple des découvertes
d'entreprise également vous avez pas mal
son oncle à son entreprise voilà donc
l'idée effectivement de toutes ces
actions là c'est de pouvoir faire
favoriser cette rencontre entre
l'entreprise et puis les écoles donc on
a effectivement par exemple développé
l'année dernière donc ça a été une
première sur le département des yvelines
classe en entreprise qui a permis à une
vingtaine d'élèves d'être immergé dans
les locaux d'une entreprise partenaire
et pendant trois jours les cours étaient
co animé préparer entre des binômes
enseignants professionnels de
l'entreprise un deuxième axe
d'intervention du club qui est l'emploi
c'est effectivement une priorité
aujourd'hui donc là l'objectif premier
c'est de pouvoir favoriser l'accès le
retour à l'emploi donc on a différentes
actions qui le permettent mais toujours
avec cette idée de favoriser cette
rencontre entre les entreprises et puis
les publics qui nous sont orientés par
ces mots différents nos différents
partenaires donc on a une action phare
au sein du club qui est le parrainage
qui symbolise parfaitement l'objet du
club qui est permet en fait à un
demandeur d'emploi d'être accompagné
dans sa démarche par un professionnel en
activité et donc le professionnel en
activité de l'entreprise partenaire va
pouvoir conseiller et accompagner le
demandeur d'emploi dans ses démarches de
recherche d'emploi donc les rendez-vous
on y est dans les locaux d'entreprises
et donc là ça prend la forme de conseil
d'accompagnement qui vont permettre à la
personne effectivement d'avancer dans sa
démarche de recherche d'emploi un autre
axe d'intervention développé par le club
ce sont des ateliers interentreprises
des échanges interentreprises entre les
entreprises du territoire autour de
sujets en lien avec les questions
d'égalité puis deux heures et ce d'une
manière générale donc là effectivement
on va pouvoir favoriser cette rencontre
entre les entreprises pour pouvoir aussi
accompagner ces entreprises dans la mise
en place d'actions très concrète et très
pragmatique à partir de leurs besoins
alors justement donc sur ses actions
pour l'emploi on
vous en avez bénéficié vous avez
bénéficié d'ateliers oui tout à fait
j'ai bénéficié de plusieurs ateliers
donc pour la technique de recherche
d'emploi
pour l'améliorer sa communication on
peut participer aussi à des entretiens
fictifs donc qui nous permet de bien de
bien nous présenter les problématiques
des recruteurs j'ai participé aussi au
parrainage donc ça a permis aussi
détendre un peu mon raison mon réseau
professionnel donc et d'avoir des
conseils aussi avec l'art chaptal donc
et gérant d'une société qui est
partenaire avec le club fasse ça permet
aussi d'avoir une démarche toujours
active et de garder confiance dans ces
moments un peu difficiles où on perd un
peu confiance par moments doux
avec une activité qu'on avale à ce
moment là quoi ça vous regarde confiance
à d'ailleurs vous a permis de retrouver
un poste aujourd'hui oui tout à fait oui
bah les conseils de capital et puis la
confiance que cas maintenu que larissa
gore ce
que m'a permis de maintenir car ce gars
voilà ça m'a permis de toujours garder
confiance et de d'aller sur les sur les
bons domaines les domaines pour lesquels
j'étais préparé alors patron vous avez
également bénéficier d'ateliers cette
fois on fait pour surtout on a comme
monument pour les 45 ans et plus donc
c'est aussi la lutte contre les
discriminations et que vous vous parlez
moi même en sourit de la même façon en
quoi ça consistait qu'est ce que ça vous
a permis en fait moi j'ai découvert
fasse par le biais de la cité des
métiers c'était lors d'une journée où on
a passé ensemble c'était fallait
revaloriser ses compétences pour les
plus de 45 ans fin des 45 et plus pardon
et c'est là qu'en fait on a eu un
contact on a passé une journée ensemble
ça nous amenons moi ça m'a permis
vraiment de redéfinir mon profil depuis
le début puisque j'ai fait beaucoup de
choses et de pouvoir vraiment ciblées
après pour l'avenir ce que je voulais
faire par la suite j'ai participé
également à
un congrès sur les seniors enfin les
l'emploi pour les seniors est à ce jour
moi je suis accompagné par clarisse
gorce qui va me voyez tous les gars ont
joué exactement les normes à douala et
là j'ai deux ateliers de prévu pour le
suivi et le suivi de l'entretien et puis
simulation d'entretien nous avons pousse
finalement allé là exactement et à me
remettre en question et a évolué aussi
avoir a vraiment un soutien
professionnel voilà ses maîtresses et je
suis très contente alors qu'on vient
finalement de personnes vous avez suivi
durant ces quinze un nom comme gerald de
patricia par exemple depuis 15 ans et
c'est un environ 3000 scolaires qui ont
été sensibilisés cemil retour vers
l'emploi c'est aussi 50 actions
déployées donc vraiment on est dans du
chiffre significatif et l'année dernière
c'était 5 plus de 50 personnes qui ont
eu un retour durable vers l'emploi de
retour à l'emploi de 60% on est un peu
pris par le temps votre carburant
finalement c'est votre réseau
d'entreprise ce et les entreprises qui
qui parraine qui participent qui
accueille les scolaires par exemple
combien d'entreprises font partie des
autres réseaux aujourd'hui alors
aujourd'hui on a 100 entreprises sur 100
entreprises qui nous font confiance qui
nous accompagnent
et donc ces
entreprises qui permettent de nous de
favoriser la proche dé monter monter ces
ateliers avec mohamed et toute l'équipe
de permanents que je salue ici
puisqu'ils font un travail absolument
remarquable est aussi un appel aux
entreprises puisque plus nous serons
meilleurs notre action pourra peut-être
l'appel l appel est donc lancé aux
entreprises qui est très intéressé les
coordonnées ça s'affiche normalement sur
l'écran n'hésitez pas donc du coup à
vous tourner pour grossir ce réseau
merci en tout cas tous les quatre à
d'être revenu sur ce plateau on passe au
tout de suite au dossier la semaine
puis mon pardon dépit d octobre de
guyancourt toi dans leurs projets
d'entreprise accès à la lance sa
brasserie locale maria ouvre une
crêperie dans le dernier épisode leurs
prêts avaient été débloqués de quoi
lancer pleinement leurs activités comme
vous allez le voir dans ce reportage
réalise avec elodie moines jonathan
willeman et roman respini
axel vient de réceptionner son matériel
de brasserie ni un matériel
professionnel qui va lui permettre de
produire en quantité industrielle
mais le problème c'est que les cuvées
armoires électriques sont posés à même
le sol dans ce container pas évident
pour les transporter dans son local mais
qu elles sont à sur palettes
tu connais en moyens au genre à
pratiquer ou vraiment la force des bras
sur price alors mais ça valait week à
peine
200 kg de foot - champions on va pas
l'élever voir fois chercher de bonnes
raisons premières opérations montées
l'écu sur des palettes
nous nous sommes aimés l'attend
ouais
avec un peu des deux la première cuvée
chargé mais il faut maintenant la
descendre heureusement un voisin lui a
proposé de l'aider en amenant un chariot
élévateur
l'opération n'est pas aisé
pourtant nous
comprendrons
petit à petit axel et ces renforts
arrivent à descendre le matériel mais
pour la plus grosse des cuves c'est un
peu la panique
attention il ya
dix ans
opération réussie le plus gros est fait
notre jeune brasseur commence à se
détendre heureusement que je pense que
la 2 3 ont
alerté très très très complices tous un
robinet dans leur local avec de la bière
à volonté
de son côté maria à bien avancer les
travaux sont finis et la crêperie a
officiellement ouvert ses portes fin
mars mais le premier soir les débuts ont
été difficiles
la panique la grosse panique on n'avait
pas assez d'électricité en fait on avec
20 ans perd donc ce qui veut dire qu'on
allume
pratiquement rien ne pousse pas la
plomberie rien et on n'avait pas de
carte bleue qu'on ne peut accepter les
cartes heureux vous n'avez pas de fond
de caisse les crêpières est s'était pas
les bonnes donc c était un faux pas ni
heureusement le vendredi sont des
connaissances qui sont venus et qui
était bientôt les
rentables c'était bien aujourd'hui le
calme est revenu dans la crêperie mais
il faudra encore une semaine avant de
finaliser les réglages pour le moment il
propose encore une carte simplifiée
pour elle
c'est bien mais c'est beaucoup de tracas
surtout en terrasse les premiers clients
découvrent les recettes de ce tout
nouveau restaurant vient souvent et
c'est dans le centre pour manger le midi
ont fait un peu tous les restes du coin
donc je suis assez fière d'ouvrir ses
tiens on va tester puis voilà tout se
passe bien on reviendra certainement
comme axel est venu découvrir les lieux
enfin
merci magnifique jeu
c'est la première fois qu'ils découvrent
le restaurant depuis son ouverture et
pour lui l'aventuré entreprenariale de
mariailles sur la bonne voie
attention d'ouverture que tu quelqu'un à
l'aja et là je suis content de venir
découvrir le restaurant la cuisine
très bonne de voir l'ambiance
et on serait bien il faut bien début
juin nous retournons dans le local du
brasseur son matériel est maintenant en
place là on a mis tout en place et les
habitants de local et après on a fait
tout ce qui plomberait et électricité
pour
mettre en service et aujourd'hui
enfin on peut le premier brassage
on va par là la première cuvée de la
bière ce inclus
finie la cuisine dans des bassines
chauffer sur des chauffes paella à qui
elle va pouvoir entamer sa production de
bière de manière professionnelle
malheureusement il a pris du retard des
pièces manquaient et il a fallu courir à
travers les yvelines pour les acheter
mais cette installation va permettre de
multiplier les rend non de manière
considérable comme par exemple pour
moudre le grain première étape de la
production avance et à la perceuse avant
je
faisais 20 kg je mettais une petite demi
heure las illas aimons
130 kg gains en
dieu c'est juste le temps de mettre les
sacs
monsieur bull aide à comprendre ces
nouvelles machines mais parfois la
barrière de la langue compliquer les
choses
victoire
non
quand les gestes ne suffisent pas
monsieur bout fait appel à son
traducteur
ok pour ce tableau qui commande les
températures des cuvées il a également
fallu s'adapter vous pouvez voir la ttf
mentionnera
pas mal discuté moi j'ai mis pas mal de
post it pour traduire et après
non c'est relativement fin moi j'avais
déjà travaillé sur du matériel comme ça
donc les fonctions je les connaissais
après c'est juste retrouver quel but qu
on fait quoi et
le petite spécificité
ce qu'il faut faire et ce qu'il faut pas
faire parce que tout ce qu'il faut pas
faire autre difficulté ce matériel moins
cher qu'un système européen ne possède
pas toutes les finitions pour retirer le
mot axel doit improviser avec un saut
mais il ne regrette pas son achat d'un
point de vue financier grâce à du
matériel le faire venir le ramener ces
gens les portes de 30000 euros un peu
plus et après eu des frais pour
l'installation donc
les listes et identifiable qu'il fallait
acheter
son billet d'avion geste comme ça j'en
ai pour cinq six mille euros en plus
j'avais pas budgétée autant que ça m'a
fait la surprise
et mais par rapport à du matériel du
belge où ce ne serait pas m'économiser
plus de la moitié du prix pour le moment
axel a déjà vendu 1500 litres de sa
bière de printemps des ventes qui lui
ont permis de rembourser son ancien
matériel et de commencer doucement à
rentrer dans ses frais
sur les bancs après a quand même des
frais au tour donc je continue encore à
perdre un peu d'argent mais j'en perds
beaucoup moins aujourd'hui il est
presque en rupture de stock mais il avec
ses cuivres demi litre d'ici cinq
semaines il pourra grossir son offre et
améliorer sa bière il a une face dans le
brassage que je pouvais pas faire avant
qui s'appelle la gare de femmes ont fait
dans les dents les fermenteurs une
baisse de la température de la bière à
2,3 degrés pendant au moins deux
semaines pendant cette phase là on fait
un gros travail sur les sur les goûts
qui se fait un équilibrage des goûts moi
je pouvais pas la faire avant parce que
j'ai pas de chambre fera mais j'ai pas
que congélateur assez grand
donc maintenant je vais pouvoir le faire
et du coup la bière va gagner en qualité
en plus d'eux en plus de monter en
quantité cet été les consommateurs
pourront découvrir sa nouvelle recette
et de dates dans cet agenda nous vous
parlions dans l'entretien du club fasse
la fondation organise mardi 17 juin en
atelier pour les 45 ans et plus sur le
thème valorisé et n'offre de compétences
de 9h30 à 12h30 matinée pour aider les
seniors à valoriser leur expérience
professionnelle en fonction des besoins
des entreprises inscrivez-vous auprès de
la cité des métiers à trappes et un
autre rendez vous à la cité des métiers
un débat avec des chefs d'entreprise
vous est proposée le jeudi 19 juin de 14
heures à 17 heures pour les demandeurs
d'emploi qui souhaitait discuter avec
des dirigeants de pme pour trouver une
solution de retour vers l'emploi et
c'est la fin de ce fil est qu merci de
nous avoir suivis je vous donne rendez
vous la semaine prochaine très bonne
soirée